can you do the music thing again
headed to meet again I keep doing that I
think I didn't do anything again so I'll
just say all that over again I do make sure
I look at the captions now and make sure
that there's like words on the teleprompter
so it happens it happens I'm just saying how
thankful I am for Leon he's talking about
Progressive web design right now and the
importance of making stuff that everybody
can use on the weather I really appreciate
what he's doing over there he's a great
teacher right man to wear as a different
style and paste and all that that's plenty
fine you know God knows I have my own style
and pace which isn't for everybody some
people think I'm a fucking asshole I think
I'm a condescending prick and then I'm
unhinged and they use all those words about
me and they continue to use those words
about me I recently it's been coming or
attack again I don't want to talk about it I
just want to say that I am really super
happy and pleased with my community and the
people that I've been able to help and those
people and how they have gone into the world
and helped others as well and
and for the many people who have reserved
judgment and despite what some random person
is decided to to do 22 to go against me I
don't want to talk about it it's just the
one of the things anytime somebody attacks
me like that really does is it it really
helps me to Center and to get busy I don't
get mad get busy and that's what I've been
saying and so if you want to do that the
Busy that we can be doing right now is going
to be making kubernetes work from scratch we
are going to install kubernetes from scratch
we finally have the means and and the motive
to commit this crime and we are going to do
it we're going to do it God damn it is so so
here's here's how we're going to do it
we actually if you want to follow along let
me go ahead and make her get repo for this
so you guys can just follow the commits to
go to make it in there, or they robbed and
you just follow me on GitHub any commits
that I make whether it be to my total cast
of notes or even these transcriptions to CC
transcriptions from the the stream or a from
these learning Labs as soon as I abandoned
them cuz I learned enough to know I don't
want to go down that route and I'll put a
warning in there but it would be if you
actually want to recreate the the learning
that I've been doing sort of kind of in your
own way as a programmer whatever you can do
that I can go there and try that so so get
in it and then they getting it is kind of
crazy and you get Republic radio. Kid file
and then when it is a GH command which is a
repo create
I'm going to use a little bit of Bosch magic
here I'm going to be dashed description
sorry kiddo get a repo
create a description actually yeah and then
in here I'm going to put a little subshell
and I'm going to grab the first line off of
the readme file and pipe that through said
I'm going to translate the first the this
does the liver the hashtag for the title and
marked down and we get rid of it and we can
use that as our description and we can do
that that way and then I'll give us the name
of the repository and it public
public annual income for the description
this time and go ahead but yes and if you're
serious here's a contact to read me this
became the description so we're just we're
just making a bass line thing we need to
commit to read me this will add it hasn't
been out yet so I had read me commit that's
a good, get out of my way I just have to get
part off Cinema stay and read me 9 D file
for the commit message and then we can get
push Dash you origin Maine it because it's
the first flush
that's just the standard way to do it and
that will get us our thing we can open that
up in a web browser and today we have a repo
that you can go to an end using so here it
is the giver is that this is the URL if you
want to go follow along you can like this
one if this is the thing kind of thing you
want to do and I don't know why my my status
hasn't updated on there
it makes me all that mad at me do Killarney
I still says I'm doing Witcher which was
really fun but I'm not doing any more
so let's see if that if they ate it
a bunch of little stuff have to update here
we have any listeners in Discord if I did
I probably I probably went to exit the stage
and just court and restart so the people
have the latest information
and then we're going to go ahead and start a
new stage in Discord if you just want to
listen too long
start with the stage put the topic
start stage I don't know if I'm able to get
the whole thing done today or not but I this
is something I've been wanting to serve a
long time and it makes me happy that we can
actually do know that we have vagrant
working so let's do that
let's do
so I guess we can keep this in here
are you all right
so first things first we are going to make a
vagrant file right after that we're not
going to do this to doctor we're going to
actually make the M's and all of the week
we've installed virtue the scripture that
read me in to stop what we're going to do so
step one
install a vagrant install
live Birds spell chemo
I never should have like prereqs on my cell
phone and couldn't hear the guests in
Discord when
no I know I'm sorry no you can't they've
been they've been banned
yeah that's because I haven't got Discord
pipe properly yet I've only been doing
Discord video for a long time for the sound
any sound from my desktop gets pissed cut
out and putting music so I've been trying to
fix that a portion and I need to fix that I
need to fix that I don't know how to do we
probably will need to bring Discord in as a
separate audio channel so that it's you know
it's it's it's being
be ready I don't know how to do it though
because
we would have to allow it either that or we
have to if we have anything like that in
front of to turn music off. Turn the music
off completely when we do that every turn
the music off then I can actually turn the
channel back on and that's how they do the
desktop stuff and then we can just go for
it. That's probably the way to go about
doing it I'll remember that next time if I
don't if I forget so but yeah I know that
nothing on YouTube ever ever has that
happened so let's talk emu
it's okay my liver hurts okay so I was wrong
we have some prereqs here here
but first i'm at that
he said the date for D & S picture you have
chemo KVM live
live Birds preferred live sh
I installed those are all kind of the same
thing
verse version song
Get set up a true Linux
our station
on bare metal
install vagrants
and configure or chemo for a Levert
All right and they'll probably put them in
order
so it's actually it's libert
and then liver cause chemo and chemo cause
KVM
yeah so I'm probably that there and I did
that already
Cardenas times out are scary
asymmetry Lennox workstation Babymetal
something I can figure for lovebirds
alright so
I don't really want to put this as
requirements or his steps
she can do the following
and I need to get a better format for this
and if so I need to talk to argue about this
I don't know if he's around right now sees a
different time frame
rme installed oh gosh
and alright so
different requirements or tasks August tasks
yes I'm kind of standardizing this little
bit
when you think you should call tasks or
should we call it I don't want to call
prerequisites right but they kind of are
here's the test I tell you how are you will
you find out
initialize a vagrant
projects
I'm going to try I will try to send you new
here and write out the stuff they plan
160 Thank you
and certified Unix
Alex Monterey is a certified Unix Seuss and
his largest set of used to play me some
World strict eunuchs right b a c units mean
is Monterey yeah
celebrity point of view Knicks in the world
right stripped Unix wow that's kind of cool
I mean you got it you got to give it to him
you know they still be a Siri but this tea
is still Unix right so yeah
initialize vagrant projects Etsy
and see how many things that we want
with
I ugly exchange or say 420 gpl3 that that I
knew because that's how come there bash was
so old
yep
it's all gpl2 yep I know I noticed that
because bash was like really really old and
then they came out Jose shell thing right
that so yeah that's what they're trying to
do they're trying to say hundred percent you
feel too
which is their home and I wish they would
just say that instead of saying Z shows
better than Bosch you know I just instead of
instead of you know trying to lie anyway
since you're here so we're doing we're doing
I am going to try to do an H A Thing
yes it does is somebody fault yet as of like
a year or two ago
so question what do you think the minimum
in vagrant in a minimum number of machines
to get a good sense of using Cube ATM I'm
thinking 3 for a beginner
I'm thinking truth be told you really only a
baby just like you can have a single love
you the control plane and then you can have
yeah it's a single control plane and two
workers right
and and that's all it's all I really need
Vigor project with
with three Central us
you know what what what do you think of it,
so it was so it was so drunk he was telling
us that he's a big Alma fan and then it's
141 exactly compatible with extreme extreme
extreme and I know you talked about using
sent to us I've been thinking about
I think 3 Enterprise
enter price Unix actually Linux virtual
machines
or three Enterprise Linux virtual machines
I'm going to fight Enterprise going to put
preferably
red hat a variance
okay so with free enterprise Fairfield in
there as soon as I reach my machines
with and I think I think we should probably
have
four course each for the one we don't really
need that we could probably have two chords
for control for exit to course each should
be fine for this to course each should be
fine for setting it up right
each with
to Coors and to give what GB Ram
2 GB Ram
22 course 2GB Ram
I think that's probably the minimum they
probably want more than that right
2 GB Ram
that's a lot that's a 24-6 that's like 6 GB
RAM and let's say 20 GB of storage actually
10-gig probably is all you need
I mean if you were if you were doing this in
the cloud that would cost you a pretty penny
that would be if it is Angelo Shannon that
would be
Barbie like 30 bucks a month
how do you say thirty bucks a month to run
out if you're doing it in the Indian Ocean
so so yeah
so let's do that or say
all right that's the first thing then what
then we're going to I'm pretty sure we're
going to make good creative control plane
so
we need to add some of the prerequisites
onto these systems so I think we need to
install a container we need to install
install a container runtime on
initialize a vagrant create a scene
create create three Enterprise Linux crate
crate 3
virtual machines for nodes
43 virtual maze machines
ants with two chords anybody storage
and what else do software and
present provision for vision with
Chris Smith each with a a doctor
no container engine
and we don't really need at this age but
Baker openssh on automatically soon
that's really it everything else was with a
container and minimally
and any other administrative towards you
wish
so that's a step was just to get that done
and then we're going to go to the next step
which is going to be putting cute video on
where the control play nodes
Rocky Ford or Oregon use Center West
where is Alma this time so
alright so let's go do it
set up a true Lennox workstation of your
mental all right so
let's do that we need to do vagrants and it
now I could have done that actually let me
let me do a better one
you can do a bigger than did file and I want
to get good with acorn in it so I need to
understand bigger
fragrance and yet you can actually
initialize the system the way you want it
so I'm going to go read about this real
quick so maker in it
all right I'm going to be about this so they
weren't in it says
I didn't name you are out you can give the
URL of the thing you wanted you want to do
this is your son is the current directory to
be very environment by Craig and just make
her file and when does not exist as giving
it will it will reap I figured they could
take a VM. Box sitting in the creative major
philant the second arguments given it will
pre-populate the config. DM box URL sending
it to create to the created vagrant file
stay in there for like a second is a box URL
are we having sex
if I fight the boxer up what's the
difference between box inbox URL
I don't know I am dime to noob minimalism
for the minimum thing probably created
having problems not contain a structural,
that's what I want for us over at output
file template
read Across America template Enterprise Ruby
I don't know that's the RV is that is a
template stuff for Ruby
generic is it generic how can you how can
you look up the the ones
there's something else you can like I think
there's like a search right
connect cloud
cloud provider public search yes Cloud
search for Elma
Mega Cloud search for searching doesn't look
like it's going to find it
but we shall see
I think we can take a long time I wish I
could
Elmo Lenox 8 Alex.
The younger I was going to say if you if
you're in the right but if you if you are
Mormon please don't be mad at me we're just
we're making Mormon jokes I turned out Alma
means a motion in Spanish I don't know if I
buy it from
so yeah he kidding me
are you fucking kidding me
how to turn the sound on for a second
oh my God I can't believe you rated him
I can't believe he raided him alright fine
whatever the fuck
Leon re2 Prime aging
you know what I don't give a shit anymore
the people that want to be here will be here
the people that don't
it's just so bad because the guy I can't
talk about it I'm going to stay positive
don't get mad get busy
I I just I can't I can't talk about it I
can't talk about it it's going to get me mad
I can't talk about it
you know what if I
I can't talk about I can't talk about it
because I can't talk about it rationally
yes where do they sell School yeah I don't
know I don't know
it's not you just start
I can't talk about it I can't talk about
because I'll use it as footage you don't
throw me under the bus again like they
always do
I can talk about it I had called and I get
called in ancient angry curmudgeon and all
this other shit and and they go against me
meanwhile they're trying to let him Jubilee
help people
whatever I don't care I actually kind of is
he's going to go tell himhe's going to go
tell him about all it look okay
let me tell you I love you if you Fortune
people are here or wondering why I'm going
to say anything at all I'm going to tell you
the reason that I'm upset is because they're
about to throw under the bus go and say that
you should use wetrust for everything and it
completely defeat everybody
plants to be able to learn go to be able to
be productive in other things
and an 8-day throw me to the bus right there
with it the problem is is that he's too so
many of these people are so loud that they
get so many people to follow him and then
they just run all these people right off the
edge of the Cliff Richards cliff
they do it right about the edge of the cliff
and and I just feel really bad I feel really
bad that I have to take stock and then the
people that I have helped have landed
200,000-plus jobs 100 to 200,000 plus jobs
and they are doing really significant things
are well beyond what these people are even
talking about and buy even saying that I get
called an asshole but even saying that I'm
trying to prepare people for more
significant employment they think that I'm
putting them all down and I think that I'm a
big ass hole and then and I didn't pedantic
and condescending I know that but still have
to walk away
well if you're if you feel like I do and you
can go you don't have to learn to Max and I
are see him and find out right now okay if
you want to learn it you can learn it
if you
you know there whatever you want I'm telling
you I'm done catering to people people
people that want to learn the stuff that I
do and the stuff that we do will come here
and they'll be fine
tell me the process but I don't know cuz I
just read a comment from somebody that was
like slamming me saying they wasted time for
3 months working on the beginner do stuff
with my stuff
and that makes me feel really shity actually
am I oh well at least you learned that's not
what you want to do in life
so just be warned
all right and I'm this close to just fucking
stopping a whole streaming thing completely
and putting my nose to the grindstone and
changing the world and working with private
people completely
I know I don't have to give up on all the
cool people but then I would just always
stay close to them on Discord and I won't
have to put up with this shit
but whatever
I know I meant all that my wife is yelling
at me she's saying to come down and I don't
leave she's like yeah I know, I'm saying
don't do that you'll be sad you lose all
your friends
she's right there you're not consumers
you're not just consumers all of you with
people I care about but that's not what
people say people are characterizing me as
somebody who hates on everybody who comes to
the kids should be there in like a tax
entire we're going to entire swaths of
humanity and I kind of do
yeah well there are a lot of people who have
been shown the records I have to focus on
them as usual you have to focus on them
meanwhile other people lie
don't get mad and get busy don't get mad get
busy get shut your mouth and get busier on
as you can see, this
I need to get laid my wife says I need to
get laid
see that's why I married you because you're
funny
my wife is so funny so funny in a car
it's stressing me out to my wife buying a
car because they won't tell us why social
solution is it going to watch the how are
you yeah she's phenomenal she's really
awesome I love her to death she's calling me
down God knows I get I get on edge everybody
knows I get on edge
so what I'm a human being
that's cuz you're so funny today if she
screams for the or you need to get laid you
just need to get my
I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to do it
on this here's here's to finding a woman
that makes you just laugh despite everything
who mirrors back to you all of your boy
bowls and flaws and still loves you anyway
cheer sir
yeah
alright where are we
but you are a condescending asshole
here's something else to being a centek to
being who you are and owning that and
warning others to stay out of the way if
they don't like who you are you know just be
who you are and if you are as a kind of
thing asshole you know you can work on that
shit and stuff but if it just turns out to
be who you are then just own it and move on
maybe you were born a villain in this life
and you just need to own warning warning
will put you down just whatever my stepson
is going to shirt that says you know
sarcastic comment loading and it's kind of
the thing and I'll have to be friends here
wife is that you
why is that you only played it whatever that
entails exactly
I mean we all do the Flyers at the end of
the day what not all of it
it's a turbo size 4 cylinder maybe there was
turbo charged
well I don't know what I don't I think
there's not a big enough it depends on the
place where yet
but driving drive me to such a pendulum is
going to be hard on you isn't it
you might need to drink here's my drink what
it was fine
I think I'll be fine too turbocharged
4-cylinder
all right what do you think should we get a
4-cylinder or a or a 6 cylinder
I forgot everything you do that's why I have
so much fun in it cuz I feel like I knew all
the time it's like eunuchs one thing that's
great about forgetting everything is
everything is always knew this is cool you
learn that last week 0
did I hear that's where Kramer to machines
with Alma we're going to create Alma
Alma the younger me to call Allan Lu of mama
jokes and it was going to get
and it in in in great respect for my mom and
Heritage of the creators of South Park we're
both Mormon raised Mormon
+ + 1
Mormon jokes. I know we're getting that
lesbian couple
yeah we're going to text my wife's words
we're getting to Subarus
because reasons
I'm going to be moving to the mountains are
going to move up to the mountains or the
driver seat and you tons
and college professors and people who in
Colorado super awesome I know they're
fishermen c.c. and I agree they know what's
up
they don't do this this did they know what's
up they know what's up alright so let's go
back
Christopher's Mercedes at Enterprise Lane
perfectly blah blah blah let's see how you
do that
I just discovered his cool command call
vagrant
Cloud search for Elma
I'll search for Alma can take a while
I said if you got I know it is I agree it's
the best it is the go-to vehicle of
everybody in Utah all the outdoor people out
Utah has like the greatest outdoor that's
why they have out to retail or you'll ever
hear
every year they got in trouble because they
were doing some stuff and they almost got
kicked out Patagonia almost boycotting them
analytics8
2D generic liver liver to use then we're
just
to use Alma Lenox 8
or should we use generic Alma each probably
is generic on the 8th
Ascension Eric Elliott shall we Shelly
vagrants
vagrant something in it generic
God I love this I thought take everything
bad but I said about mad about Meghan
ever since I got liver to work which wasn't
variants fault M8
I think it has been placed in your directory
thank you very much they grunt I've got I've
got to do minimal
and I'd do it again yeah that does minimal
and I hate that all that shit they put in
there there we go. Going to type that but I
remember
alright now I this isn't enough of a thing
for me to remember as well and so we need
I don't know how to do so I think we're
going to do with libvirt right
I can't remember the syntax I cannot
probably good I don't use middle next time
I take it all back
fine I'm still a noob so so I'm going to go
get it later and file
sure, Lenox got it it could be gracious
comments
vigorous vigorous is done at the 2nd
McPherson figuration version
with what are the side effects of a please
don't change it unless you know what you're
doing you got it just a lot of money box of
David checks
false no creative creative for mapping which
allows access to specific Port within the
machine for Port Angeles machine
we need to actually do this but not right
now
coronavirus told me that you never told me
that
enable search box no
we're going to do the stuff we do need them
baby gooey do you want to do it you
and it would be fun at all I don't know the
Glee would even look like
I don't know BB memory we need 2048
how do I get more than one though I do at 3
got to do like three of them
I guess I must have to VB memory
meet with Vivi. See if you write 2
PB. CPU equal to
I never got your disk volumes right we're
definitely provisioning
British owl in line are there in line in the
shell
this is cool
where are you that's what we're going to use
straight up for vision
I-24
what was on TV how are you
hope things are good I really do Shelf
is that really going to work though that is
a question
accurate update installed why Apache I think
we're going to install docracy
assuming you can hear he has probably gone
should we do container D or should we do
I know yeah
I printed them and doctor wanted to see you
today since with her into printing
I know I agree well this is your car right I
I don't want it
there right there that was there already
they were that that was that was their
mistake
do we have two disc disc actually no we can
do plan
let's do a plan shall we
Isuzu migrant plan
I know plan is a thing is Earth find KVM
Kimmy thing
what the hell plan Dash h
is that not a thing I kind of smart as a
plan
for provision plan destroy Publix I'm mixing
up on my my stuff autocomplete
how to complete a aqueous solution on host
thank you for that cat should you be
status episodes that's why I've been going
to Grandma's for this user
Saturday sell transits races of the bigger
machine his helpers on command
I think there is a plan
I I don't know I think we just have to do it
I don't want to run up on my desk though
you know what there's a thing to look at sup
when you look at the files that can assist
stuff
god dammit play Grinch Packer console
know where is the a tradition where where is
that
syntax what is syntax
I don't know
vagrants I'll send text we need to go
through my study this how did you find it
thank you you're the best you the best
Supreme
acid reflux Ruby it's right how recent
explained
and what is that we have well connect in it
yes
looking for the prefix a big problem
describe the type of machine required for
project I had a bigger Provisions but she's
bigger files are called Falls Because the
actual little file name is Megan Phile make
a dispenser was wondering about for project
big UPS in Texas Ruby
look up at when you were leaving her command
man climbs up the directory tree Universe
maker it make if I can find my first in the
current directory so if you're in Vegas and
it'll climb up good teacher is Red Bluff
emerging actual does a series of bigger
files emergencies as it goes
I thought maybe if I was a very low level of
specificity over
yes of course cylinder and it's and I just
compare it to the two that I saw that were
local
is going to drive out your door a right on
your doorstep
my wife is ordering a car they're going to
deliver it like Amazon to the front door
because he isn't this one it comes to 8900
you know you pay more money up front and
more money in gas
I don't I don't I don't I want the
4-cylinder green reimagine green cards
yeah go order it ready to go Jesse's deathly
going to yell at you oh my God
that's a no-brainer her coronavirus I think
yeah
yeah she told me just as what
interesting you can just decide
all right
can the machine delivered it to you they
sell the setting set Sunnyside will be
merged with previous by what is exactly
depends on the same for most settings it's
me sitting here saying he's already knew the
other one hour for things such as many
networks actually finish the other guy is
supposed to be bigger config
that is not enough I take your thing here
how to make a dress I think we did it
already in here to me yes we did thanks boom
a boy oh boy
you know what people that you'd learn on
those eunuchs philosophy
are going to be Head and Shoulders better
off in the long run
then those who don't a subjective truth I
don't have to be pretending about that is
super jacked of Truth
rivian alarm at December navigation
no Mesa dress IP and Boots check out date
load
where's disc
I am just stores very spiritual
justification sewing machine from
experimental
aggravated freezing volume for that don't we
discs discs can I give him
disc I guess not
configure disc special Jessica come dis you
found room for those two
all right
oopsy
this couches
because a separate thing so
I have this config I could give you a disc
you can't just type the first argument just
backup size
I think this thing has come back up send a
Skype
I guess we have been critical to find this
after Vader finish this cat has a lot of
stuff here
a lots of stuff I guess I guess that's here
I mean we can look all over the place for
that stuff we don't really need to
as a disk size has a website ready
what it what was it love you doing today we
are doing
what was it then why can't you singer
hanging file has it in there
it prison Network Shoppers near me have that
has refused 2048 and receive his two
eernisse
yes yes sir
2 2 2 2 2 2 2 V
no we don't want to rush you want live verts
V
the we want this to be 2048 if you sue
I think we went dark to see honestly I don't
know who you are not but
Ecuador doctor C and I didn't see how big
the disco's but fault
what is a Scorpio I have a question I have
is how
how do you make multiples of these you know
how do you call it for like if I want more
than one
so I guess I'm running right into the like
project-based kind of learning so
and God
what's a disc example of adding vagrant
disc
there you go I figured you could fix me a
magic word to him. Box provider versus box
wait what a Shakur a 7 p.m. to box
sfm. Disc
are they didn't figure being
I got to see this one is this not showing
proper way you can fake a fake a VM Define
haschak or oh you got more than one VM
that's what I want I want a lighter live
Birds
anything you want a baby sound like my song
My Song provider right we just want it
in Frederick was where to buy bikes
yeah I just have been way better I don't
know how much you like the way I don't like
this whole by provider shit we definitely
want that so can you give me a minute to
find
config him. Define
I'm going to say it's real plane
who playing I ever see if search engine area
do buck and Sergeant time
end see that box a while we can do some
box away we can do some hair I think 222 in
a box
if and then boxer fighter nice
it's a very box ACP
I know it's a master at our main is there
may know it's how's it going Harlem Prime
how are you
Isuzu main for this and a box
end. End on a Friday that provider
I am okay I got it as soon as a tough day
but I'm getting over it
what's a great day until I read YouTube and
twitch no surprise there
Levert
disc I like that I'm totally stealing it
I mean if it's around for stealing what are
they for
an m-disc we're going to have her anyway so
I got 10 gigabytes
I mean yeah it should be fine primary true
memory
MDOC memory m. Cpu2
and provision that she'll thing
yeah we need darker on all of these you know
it says that it's like it's
it says that it kind of adopts the other
ones
this is so I'm happy I hope the rest of your
day is better nice glad you got in when the
Supreme of course you got into something at
school
on a couple thousand we have it we were
studying the same amount I would do 2000
so so what I think
I think there's a way to Ness vagrant files
so that everything uses your comments thing
and then you add more stuff to it and I mean
I was offering to hear what a great job I
mean a great class
was it always just suffering that was
Computer Engineering or Miss read it or
whatever kind of fun to hear
when it when it hears there's a question I
have for bigger in this this this evening is
me exploring vagrant so if you're not into
that you know that's that's what we're doing
I think it's an old Tech you know and it
used to be but I want to be able to do I
want to be able to take the beginning of an
image and say I want all this other stuff to
get the same as that image but I want it to
subclass that and add more stuff and I mean
and I'm almost positive you can do that I
just I've never done it don't know how to do
so I text you to your hard drives
I just extra storage
and I scored uh box bionic by the mostly
yeah sure funny I hate you know what you're
going to have to learn like a dozen
languages or so if you want to be a good in
Tech eventually so
I'll look at that look at that I'm going to
have to learn Ruby shit I'm going to have to
actually learn Ruby again
093 each Duets like ancient what kind of a
cab driver in that movie in years
just cuz I dig this gives you 3 discs
it makes me think I need to do this for
nodes I could kind of do that
I could kind of make three nodes attaching a
few drives God damn
goddamn have I feel so bad she suggests you
I got it sold it already I can't believe I'm
getting as much as a ruby
there's been really upgrading a credit from
Source insulation come man does
it's good that they can share no I can file
yes please big on file
it's been an awesome yeah Ruby is pretty
much the best configuration language ever I
mean it really is fantastic for it
refrigerator house describe the type of
machine blah blah blah blah blah
Cynthia Rose by another requirement is not
necessary to make modifications that group
is not even the most Popular Community Bank
or is using which should help show that you
aren't that despite I haven't really known
as people are very successful with Veyron
here's a low cross every platform supports
look at that when we talked about that on
this in in larger font in files Etc
reminder specific overrides yeah
what I want to know is how to group stuff
being the bigger versions of the tricks I'm
sure it's here
replace closest Ruby Loop over the ends
that's this one talking about this is what
I'm talking about right there that's exactly
what I was looking for him
I appreciate that they did that
never better she'll inline hello kit for No
21 yes please we want three nodes each do I
so cool
0 to 3 1 2 3
1 2 3 we will have. It's due
I and and then and then
is a VM Define goddamn is it cool
config. I am. Define
what is the template
yeah he's always have those God damn I
haven't been receptive and forever
no I can't even type
so there we have no. I do node
in node
see how we do that and we can pop up free
knows all once so wheat
so we each to try it I'm actually done into
dry this pretty gel
yes Echo
node I want us to actually replace
I I don't know we're driving we can try
vagrants up
failed the sitting service is reproducible
convenience expected in and of course you
did what was I thinking
Sonny's to go over
indeed thank you some people still like me
apparently
this is Ruby of all things you think you'd
see that here it is actually still one of
the big languages for security to because
it's all written and Ruby originally it was
raining really I think I opened it up now
moral of the story is you have to know more
than one language to be good in Tech
what a surprise right
oh my God bring up machine on with with
liver provider and Erica are all be shown
all tasks completed
compare an interactive Ice King there's
bigger unknown configuration see if you
section equals
I feel I feel not very smart
cuz you don't need it I need to equal sign
here cuz it's not yamral goddamnit or like
whatever
big enough it can't possibly be done
remember coronavirus given to
why the hell find vagrant lines 7 7
well I don't know but what
is it a, Nubian provision shell
inline blah shell
show in line tell him what's up there
do not do not know what is up with that if
you think they could I do
all right let's look in one session ha Luna
Bakery configuration
sorry we're I so find this very fun
middle settings in address string I want
examples I don't do Wellness examples
it's a lot to see yeah she's pretty good too
obviously foxes provisioning
basic overview are you
make a provision
all right so it's different
overview networking automation I need to
find a more examples
when I got some Ranger I have a I haven't
had an error at what is
I do not know I know not
we're not going to argue is given to a line
is your Alma I think
is that right
I don't know montego's extra weight equal
signs
so I have it wrong I haven't wrong
I know I did that way disguise
I ain't do nothing wrong oh boy I don't
figuration section
damn it I don't know Ruby and it is spin
forever
they can fall or you I don't I don't I have
to hurry to get this in texts
configure be in Genesis how you doing
Grandpa Jones
do you know where the shell and 9 block
all right I'll leave you alone you just goes
cuz if you change the value it's not work
or I guess I should actually my face value
most host local
find assistant to help me make a Fabian real
settings
is your summit viewing box its configuration
is here with box and she has bronchitis
I wish what's the name of this song rain
cloud
it I don't see what's up there I don't know
unless it doesn't know what it is
if you have a box something is not right of
Italy bigger file
no no no note that if you end up box
or is that config.ini in the Box I want to
know
it is to think of your mailbox it is it's
not node
Shelby Rodriguez yes I think that's
st. Matthews I don't know fam machines
I don't know I honestly don't know fidget
boxes overview
steering box is in the Box ad
can I grab a config. I don't think it's
supposed to be node
I guess was to be no. Listening
so I guess it's the obvious obviously Citrix
and it being that person why is it not happy
about
not memory I see if you
I made it farther this time an error
occurred of a shown after
I said he shouldn't exist if your memory
there are secretions between the fox say you
shouldn't exist or I find all right fine I
got your point so see this is to
but why is it take me to Center in Ellicott
City.
Alright so we're so it's fine to see if you
section yeah was that VM
lendup box is a string
download p.m. fox box Luttrell Cloud disc
pmqs host name
I said I should have huh
I guess I got to do no 21 what is a use for
I mean vagrant for fun at mostly mostly for
boot camps who helped you do an old-school
bootcamps to do Ruby on Rails that's its
most common usage second-greatest usages in
security and medical database and vagrant is
so that you'll find old stuff that's been
done in it make sure it's very old hag been
around for a long time
so provider provision is range
and yes disc them box version
box that has a makeup box I think we do I
think we have to make a box that has a
vehicle that has the storage unit and then
associate the box with the storage
that's what I think has to happen yeah cuz I
don't see anything about
I don't see anything about Mary
adequate
so
box version creating a bass box amigo the
situation could have bass box
doctor bass box is VMware visual box I miss
my son explore the doctor baseball gloves
is a pack of the crate reviews will build
yes that's their own product the space
memory for Phil's audio this is not working
vagrant Festival Studio
what the hell
I was going to make a box that can be
published that's all we want, we want we
want to actually put it in original box
things taking way too long is it going to it
is taking way too long
I think I'm ignorant plugins host
at some point VM
if you have allowed them all Associates Mac
address boot being boxes
that should be the name of the cell blocks
that's your head name
TeleCheck some Fox Talent search search
search secure URL
version a clarinet Communicator disc we got
that result I'm out in gas hose name
Network puts up provider Anarchy slivered
where is the First music variation which has
used his return provider it's a live web
framework Sam Visions on the machine bubble
gun
I do understand there is literally no where
is it say anything about CPU in any of the
bigger dogs
and that's the whole fucking point I think
it is
Central exact am I wrong
I mean how well I know how to fix this cuz I
already did it
it was my provider though and that's the
thing I'm confused about
sing a setup
zbrush a specific provider specific
that doesn't make any sense
if their provider specific then okay I think
I know what we have to do then we have to
inline them if we're going to do it like
this yeah that would that's not immediately
obvious so that means
if they are providing specific so we do live
like this right and
Amityville, and probably do memory
I have no idea if you have any memory equals
2048 or colon
, CPU colon
2 I bet you that's it
what you think oh you found something
thanks for that thank you for that having
fun
and increase memory
yeah this is just for this for time to find
the rim size if you can like this but that
that means you might have to change it every
time I want what if I want to have a
different size for each one
I mean I mean I see that that's a thing that
you can do
I said was a okay so it's a property of
provider right
make bubble gum
but then how can I have been whole point is
to have another virtual machine I don't have
to decide right
I mean when they do that
I'm sad I mean it's like so go ahead last
Hunter Chris memory
being provided with a box to do blogging
arguing Nordstrom
so so what I want to know is I mean it looks
like I'm doing something that's tricky
that's tricky so I'm kind of out of you know
around here
it does not listen to make any sense because
why are CPU a factor of the provider are not
a factor of this Pacific p.m.
the main models broken MC and I'm saying and
it made him also the fucking broken it's
like
I mean I did that just doesn't make any
sense to me
I have a feeling that I'm doing it close to
the right way but I don't it's obviously not
that way
if I don't keep those memories of you
a maybe maybe even equal sign and it is it
that that doesn't who knows
I mean I can do it by saying and giving the
provider of those parameters but I don't
have to change the parameters every time I
know it doesn't make any sense I know
everything is valid
I don't I don't believe that's valid I don't
think you can write that I don't know
I mean I can do
okay so it's a different provider if I want
to have a different be I might have to
change the sizes for all the provider then
for the provider's dynamically as I'm going
along making GM doesn't make any sense it's
like a totally fucking broken the main model
I I see I see how to get it to work but I
don't want to do this because it's like
I mean it's a hack
they they want us to do is probably I mean I
make it to work but I don't want to so many
memories we used to farm
UPS in Agawam and that should do it
and that is stupid
it's always something I have a feeling death
disc is not associate with that that's going
to feel next I think disc is outside the
realm of um
Matthew 08 the professor didn't work
you didn't like my shut bathroom temperature
does not exist in the system
pictures of falling or striking Casper shell
provisioner
I'm talking about path for shell all right
fine
all right fine
I have inline set so why is it I don't think
it likes to the center
I don't want to see so, path, and we don't
have a bath
do you need that we shall see
I need the shell for Valiant provisioner
how many things understand you though so I'm
actually kind of encouragement that
show overview of provisioning
Iverson Bakery has up it runs I first
figured I'm crazy about him pushing his run
it was already crazy is up and ready to just
isn't running.
I just called the provision flag was because
the first music you bring up your vitamins
and explicitly not run version by saying a
nice okay so
shell
The Shield provider in line that's why I
String Ashoka Madeline text you when I'm a
machine to Neon Lights from session path
string that's a shell script
script to upload is our path like doing in
line a complicated shelter for bruising is
not good
I don't like that path of provision
do you do this provision hey sissy
Pace the Senate won't see
all football yay team
yeah I got us we're going to have to do our
own timing in there and everything but
whatever mods for vision
proxmox up
what am I saying fractions for a stupid
vagrants up
looks happy
Alma the younger not to be confused with
maroon tie
Shadrach Meshach in a Bendigo or any other
religious entities
from mythology if I can kidding me
are you fucking kidding me
okay I see how it's going I see how it's
going
yeah yeah I see how it is I see how it is
yeah I see how it is I was in the house
hey look at it after you make a sound maybe
cuz I need you to do first
provision you got to see her all the things
unfortunately
find the first auditioning for this year's
March and run always will still run
it looks kind of okay
I don't know how can we do bigger ass to see
if it doesn't work anymore it doesn't want
to connect you
haha no one
who who El Metate we have the bigger any
kind of el mate
now what is input the note there no shame
that would have been a thing to do
I'm inside the host name vagrant or going to
say those name
node that VM. Was it host name
I don't want to call Alma 8 I ain't even say
that I didn't even see the host name
no it did not it did not it did not do not
argue with me
I know if it is a studio actually so so so
so
and I'm going to go ahead and go back where
we were
I don't want to search it takes forever to
search
takes forever to search no way this way I
don't like it
so I'm a search Megashare this is Sage
was that was that
Hellboy oh God
what you got for me there is no such thing
as share
No Such Thing this is a rare LOL
this is cool I mean it's very much like keep
CDL which I love so I need to do hostname
I'm going to say
I knowed no dash star sign am I
I think it's those damn I don't remember
vagrant
Ray Kurzweil OU name
just listen to vagrant what is it that we go
and see him. His name already
VM that host name alright vagrant
hello. Just provision I wonder if it will
fix it or if I have to destroy the whole
thing
we shall see
that was I took me have a lot of time but
his first time I've used a grant ever and
now I'm finding it to be very useful abdomen
not found fuck you
it does seem to be doing it though
wait a new app did there's no I have kids
of course. Of course not of course
I'm so sorry
I can only laugh at myself on that one that
was that was very silly very silly
I forgot research pretty funny today see
this is the kind of thing you should watch
base OS app stream extras let's get them all
got to get them all at the Pokemon thing
right I don't know anything about Pokemon I
haven't watched a single episode as a true
my wife a half-hour episodes Once Upon a
Time my kids I don't remember it
how to say try yum
I didn't answer so I can see that was a wild
guess okay that's what it's called that's
what doctor is with our communication is
called in a while and apparently it's not
present elsewhere
so yeah you think I'm going to do
did the did the did the
tutu tutu tutu tutu tutu tutu
it seems like it's busy though
it is taking longer than I would have liked
course at the end of the day it has to do a
lot. Can I can I do it so that it doesn't
occur in Lee
I wonder if it's like concurrency thing and
I mean God damn it didn't replace it
it's a very sad I'm very sad nevertheless
it's just another one this time no it does
not a time in minor name
I will not look at the Moon
I sit the hostname why did you not work why
you no work config. V n
host nameis it is it outside of the M scope
I feel like it failed so we have a new host
name
why isn't even there it should not be there
that was a mistake
I didn't pick up the hostname That's that
wears me all that
it makes me wonder if I need to do can you
get VM
I know saying I don't know here to Duke
give him a box of Krampus as soon as they
said after you crave games
I'll take a rest after cuz you with your
plan do this every person within a bunch of
itself okay so that's not that's not a thing
you do currently
I think it is facts I guess that's not a
thing that you do
is think bigger and says yes that that I
know so so I just didn't want to come on
thing
they all are all identical that's fine
that's no fun except that accept that
installing docker addition until
sent to us or whatever.
Remove docker it is just so early
I can see the decoration package now doctor
see which I try to install
and it did not find it
vagrant SSH known one
we stalker Sea-Doo Young
that's why I install Docker C activox
dispatch.
I need someone to write another guy
money interest rates
Lenny's Sub Shop atomy USA
cook at this cuz that's I knew if I talk to
you
Sea-Doo
are there anywhere to do that yeah yum
search Doctor
they must have added it to the Elmo s
distribution packages are not very full
compartment doctor of course
I mean compose container
they don't have doctors to eat shit
container d
do they have potato do you please send me
the opportunity
I am losing my interest in Elma as an
operating system
because if it doesn't have the standard
stuff I don't know if I want to fuck with it
dr. Felton I'm just going to have to add a
few PA or something like that for doctor
installing docker Ciana Center West
yeah
you saved our supposed to be something there
because I like her just a very depending on
your needs
Repository Emma tells config manager okay I
guess we need that
Emma tails had already I think manager
I have never used him so this is really good
I mean I have used that I used it a ton but
then it was like 15 years ago
all right Sam out of your right that looks
like a man that actually worked
therefore we shall add it has been blessed
bless you bless you
getting medicine on her manager could take
berninger and a repo
ABS darker Etc I'm using the mouse sue me
sue me
all right so that should work I ate the
second utils are getting installed on
automatically so I don't think neither
unable to proceed nightly nightly I think I
want that
why do we not nightly there's no point I
don't even ever thought about another
Channel
yeah let's see if we can sell that if we can
actually saw it on the thing now on the
thingamabob
any repo weather at work just
I don't think it worked I don't hook
pseudo young that's why I install doctor C
okay only it's working alrighty
that is all we need
set my wife got back from our walk with the
dog show my for a lock that we've been fun
so you're giving manager
and if a doctor now. Going to come then I
said I was starts with a c and repo
enable the nightly in Chester close
Aaron is a sister best musically I don't
need it I don't need it
dr. clivio
how did the doctor say last not a bad thing
so let's add that
it was on that
slime
complete nothing to do
is already installed I forgot you're even
sold separately I remember doing that on
another project I didn't I was like hey
those are all redundant is his my
workstation container project
don't need any of that hackers unites
hackers Unite
we are the 1% that's the slogan from Amanda
don't over the where
I this is it I think we're done I think I
think I finished the main first parts of it
now it's kind of like your Cube ATM and
stuff like that I think we're going to go so
yeah that's right I'm just read the whole
thing and I'm going to redo it
so when do vagrants destroy
I'm going to hold a rash to see if it works
and it should the other day we should have
three provision nodes of identical situation
going on and then we can go ahead and do
Hugh ATM yet this the vagrant that way this
way I kind of the script it's the
configuration right for vagrant it it in the
provisioner runs it's the first thing that
runs on the newly provisioned machine
virtual machine
and so yeah how's it going to be if your
brother can you see and
what that means is that the reason I did
this is because I want to bring up
this is pretty personal I've never had a
friend like today is my birthday if so I'm
not okay with this but you know I want you I
want to be able to bring up a bunch of
virtual Machines of specific specs and
proficient specific provisioning really
quickly on my machine I don't want to have
to walk around the cloud or any of that
stuff I just want to have it on my machine
so I can go in and test different stuff and
that's what I'm using to so this is a loop
that lives through three times using crates
three, which is a CV according to chunky it
is the best of the best when it comes to it
has far fewer bugs than stream which is
another sentiment switches has been taken
over by by redhead it's also Alma is also
independent of red hat which I like
completely out of sight right accountability
so they didn't this wishes you design are
based on Enterprise Solutions said that you
you get you know what the Enterprise feel
and you have to do this if you want to
we install kubernetes because communities
Wikipedia that's if you were paid by
contract firm like I am to go to a company
and insecurities and get it all set up this
is exactly what you would have to do you
write a script like this but you might
actually write a script like this it depends
on how many big writing may be due to her
former ansible which is why we stuff to
learn those things and then they would chop
out a bunch of gems for you and then you
would install it and keep it in and going
through the process has been so I can
register you can meet him it's something
I've never done it something I've never not
been to Salt been working for years and
committees admin and that's something I've
never done because I've been struggling with
how to get that to get to the point where
you can do that without buying Cloud space
on Amazon whatever and this this is by far
the most knowledgeable people that I've
watched on YouTube I mean really truly
knowledgeable people who was very very few
subscribers and Watchers because they're
just fucking awesome they're not marketing
people
nail sucking on it yeah yeah terraform
ansible yeah they're all they're all a
little bit but at the end of the day you
have to provision machine Singer sewing
machines usually and you have to be able to
install using keep ATM on there and you need
to be able to go in and need to be able to
add another and the control playing those
are all things you can't do unless you have
a machine you can't practice S7 mini Cube
I'm sorry you can't you can't practice with
me to give you a sweet kind you can practice
with physical machines when it's a pain in
the ass because you have to reimage them
every time you want a new one so this kind
of stuff the best way to practice is either
in the cloud or using something like vagrant
to do the send I watch two different people
on YouTube to do this and they are almost
impossible to watch their their quality
videos of just about everything but the way
that they just used to a vagrant to just pop
up a whole bunch of stuff and show you how
to
initialize kubernetes is very it's very
unassuming and it's very it's very advanced
in and it doesn't have a lot of handling and
it's just fucking amazing and so that's
that's where I learned about nature and then
I got kind of profit by its ravenous in lack
of support for the verdict which turned out
to be delivered from that vagrant and so
then we're back to a good spice Play Store
and I'm very very happy
you know there's one solution when there's
actually one solution to being frustrated
and nervous and mad and feeling like you're
getting put down you know that answer is
getting busy making cool shit
getting busy making potion
Kreischer tongue we're fine with ph be all
day today with the doctor making cool shit
and BHP there you go not bad and moderate
HPI I took a moment to look at it with three
Jenny when she was here
solicitous let's do
let's do something here let's do I don't
think we can you keep medium yet actually I
think I honestly I think we're done I think
we're actually done
rigor SSH node one
I've been craving for a nice man run
Megaforce I wish I could
I was going to I was going to make a a
function in Ruby I need to know if I could
if I knew Ruby I can make a function that
into which I pass a variable and I mean
and I can actually call it but I don't know
how to do that
I try not to do function Ruby
hey bro I protects the processing fee and
how are you doing I'm still processing
is it really deaf do you think I could do it
if I didn't. You think I could call into it
and pass it in a variable and then and then
replace it
reviews of Henry yes
when it when I want is I don't want it to do
three of them I want to actually call the
function three times with different names
what I think I can do I don't think I can do
because cuz this has to be in scope right
config has to be in the same scope can I can
I do in a closure
can I have can I have to find a close around
here can I do this
deaf make
and then Jamie and then this could be
is it be the name God damn
how to pass an argument to it I do not know
SA
it's kind of good I'm kind of Happy
I do I think I think it is called a closer I
think you can do it
I'm almost positive you can't swim the great
things about Ruby best arguments
can I just run inside of here I think I can
write on python you can
so I just need to find out how to define
I didn't do Ruby okay death High that's
literally it
are you kidding me deaf name right
and descend descend to go to the config
right
so we could do then I could do make
can you just pass it like this
this isn't pythons Ruby
how do I call it though
Methodist method High. Predators
fuck no Chiara Smith and a star from Earth
I forgot about the association I forgot
about that method method no hear. Predators
shut you can't
I don't think you can
we need to really like her close yours
closures in Ruby
all right so closers lock name
do you put inside him 2 item 47 if I really
miss us
I don't know if it's once
print once arrested for this fall back
Prescott yelled at fuck now I don't yield
I can hate you if we have to use those
foreclosure fuck it I hate that that's like
one of the worst things ever
pregnancy Medical nope ha
I mean we should be able to close right this
is an easy thing I just want to repeat this
three times
so how do I do that
could I could I pass three things so it
could find do you know I can't do that
because I have to Loop
this is a function call to say I'm calling
them to find do
this on it and pass it no no no never so
how can I do that
I mean I think I think it's possible I just
don't know
it's okay if I'm not about you done in
Russia
okay so let's do what do they say
and if you write and Ruby I don't know how
to fix it if I could probably put it if it's
a problem with that is I lose all the embeds
going to mean
so I would lose this I have to pass I don't
think this is a symbol that can be passed
cell I don't I don't think it is I don't
think this is some of the can be passed
so what I couldn't do is they couldn't going
to rain is not numbers
yeah what's that control plane
no one
I supposed to call him to drop his anywhere
there's a new name for it what is the new
name for control planes in kubernetes
controller manager stop playing
control plane components I knew master and I
suppose, Master now because recent sweat
is Newnan I think I think it's just control
I think I have a move for that referral one
node one I think was going to call in those
10 to I think this will work
it's cuz I want to have any games each
how do we have a 4 and do
name and then
to do vagrants up damn it they Grant a
driving. I really not the case but that
needs to be in a r a
you make an array of strings and Ruby
RV
oh my God I be I'm going to be in town I
totally forgot
Erin file shit
array iterate over
list of strings and I have no idea w
restringing Ruby splits
Char's each
I need to make an ice make a list for
who-knows-where be I do not
Char's that each what I need to do is make a
list
I need a list
listen to Ruby
music sets
each each each each sorry I thought you were
off
I hide his brackets
is there a reason rain yeah but I don't
think
you know what actually I think it is that
I think it's that's them because
ignorance yeah I think I think because the
only one that knows this is his range I
think it was because it was arranged I think
this is because of the list
yeah recurrence app
and I never expected
oh I had another end in Kelvin
I think this is going to work I really do
so that way I can do him I wanted to give
him different names you know
I'm time for me to watch and go to bed I can
wake up bright and early get back to work
really always artist yes they look at that
node one control to super happy about that
you have no idea
I'm very very happy I'm exceptionally happy
I had a feeling he was going to the gym but
you should
we don't need you to do so we should be fine
interesting Linux why are you putting it on
there
I didn't tell you to that
I guess part of I think I think Enterprise
read how it has asked if you wanted to meet
at fault I hate as the owners
I was going to tell you going to be like a
true infrastructure generation.
Exactly.
It's two two two two two two two two two two
two two
it has to do each one I wish you would do
they synchronously is that too much for my
computer to handle
I think it might be holy cow my provisioning
failed though
I didn't fail but this part failed which
makes sense he's no longer in the phylum or
so
this is quite awesome vagrant list
vagrant status
look I'm be still my heart
a secure it is secure and it's required I
just doesn't make it so hated
I don't know any qualified that so there's a
hate things are actually cuz they're bad and
sometimes I hate things are annoying and SE
Lennox is annoying in good so let me be
clear
that is awesome I have my own career days
already and I just had to run a command and
you can run a command to just install
vagrant and you can run this command you can
up your own environment
I wonder what my top is doing
and like I'm not even like overly stressed
my systems not overly stressed to see if you
it's it's more stress than it usually is but
it's not like crazy crazy stressed
and this is even in the middle of a pop OS
meltdown look at that don't have any
anything for my menu Cinema menu show
anything and I crazy
so there you go
and there you go that is so awesome I
actually watch SSH vagrant
Ray Grant SSH node one Ellis
fine fine
LS which doctor doctor PS
can I connect the doctor Damon socket is
there a darker NES
I forgot the name of the doctor Damon which
I don't know how to do but this is all part
of setting up a few days so so there
sudo systemctl doctor
doctor service is inactive Jed Jim she's
dead
she's dead we need she's dead you in I think
I have to have that right now actually
I know it's a boomer reference I don't give
a shit
he said Jim He's dead Jim
I'm a doctor doctor
eye doctor dammit Jim
but attention
that's good enough
I don't think he's popping in my head is
this one
are your parents or your parents dead
are they dead all day dentist
I don't think it got I don't think it got
done sport alert people died in Harry Potter
I don't think it got recorded cuz it's not
it's like a tiny little vignette I need to
make it
is there there is
where your parents
where is your mom you should get
she said she said it's just a delivery
delivery on that is totally perfect
she got it she did Aramark
she did is she dead
it's so horrible I love it
Mercedes that actor the guy who plays
there's Lee
he's amazing he's amazing human being he's
in the chest one you know is it a lot of
other stuff he's going to basically being a
great actor it's nothing like it's character
at all
she said we obviously have to activate this
shit so
Docker at as soon as I got to practice in
systemctl enable
why am I spending so much time making this
stupid thing fell because any time that I
want to pull up a base install and practice
installing cabinets from scratch I can go
through and I can do that 10 times I can do
it a dozen times I can give you guys a
bigger if I can do it yourself so you can
practice and selling communities over and
over again and you won't have to invest the
time and learning maker and you can just run
it right and you can't be a bit darker
because it doesn't have other things you
need to do this so this is the next best
thing that's why I'm going through this I am
going to try my hardest to keep to the
security said it all produce anything
resembling boost and some of the stuff I'm
doing right now is actually in line with
that
says I'm going to do
I want all this brilliant oh God yeah
they're they're telling all those amazing
before the cameras also amazing and weird
enable what are the name of the doctor
suncalc what the fuck what is that oh my God
that's pretty damn cool that is pretty damn
cool they give me that link
are you guys seeing this are you seeing this
only tells you when the sun is coming up and
where it's going
giving it where you are very nice
very spectacular and ice already go to
Google Play Store I don't
let's check the statues of Darker inactive
kiss my ass
enable Dash now I've learned his way to do
that
Russian company Time Blog
I thought it was yell at the risk of threat
as yellow
the good ingredients for a 14mm photography
video
if we chill city which is Alicia if she
sweet merciful as
Frozen is a mentor program glue glue strain
steroid throw another stereo through it
no setting ways that we said they could not
courteous to Kelowna Nippers Corner
steroids steroids in the stroller
okay I got it now I got it says it looks
like it looks like a regular map regular
globe of the map on steroids
legally cut weekly car glueckert in Estero.
Little Bunny Foo Foo
Isuzu Isuzu from the bottom needs to be
quiet what can I do with Zak Zak Zak Russia
b u s s e b green
zika virus zika virus if you have to drop
him because he has a cats to eat the coochie
we Moto g g g g g g g g g n
if I go to anybody. Wow
this is how you learn Russian read it every
day read it every day
Russian French in English
it's instrument Kotori come get him but not
for the graffiti video which city which is
read me a miscarriage in your sink looks so
certain he's got over in the morning so I
can live with that. At least that you would
still going to cost yet to Croods
wow make my mouth is tired I need to take a
break
Analyse this isn't actually this is a thing
that they were showing us the other he's
been sending like a douche
the time. The time that we play Mia
the News 9 polishing you we know the date
and the time but we don't know the position
of the sun
at the video below. Up
Alpha k at the video below Vidalia know
Bullock Governor approval coconut I want to
say it right now
nothing video achieve achieve
I shan't leave it I shall leave it I think
that's you can notice right with the video
chat with me Jenny Jenny mr. If you schedule
music kids music
powder
Potter through galsky
wow
Alex
no
navigate me to my wrist to get a shield Easy
Street
is that what you do you have a scanner
ghosty
how do you say it's part of Moscow
no I done a gene is Eddie. I wish I was with
you
the membership at the Patriots if they match
Asia as well as story per story for children
how do you spell privately
but you but you book me a doll shirt
that's supposed to see what he's supposed
to. Am I nice
I'm sorry guys I'm just complaining in
Russian I'm renting in Russian
Pleasanton play play play the for sale
no y'all feel y'all be up there just to see
if she pissed at you that's if I don't
isn't it okay opportunity to about Little
Pony the song
Samoa Joe
Sheboygan people to say much you know if I
have well just in case you don't do it
there's a schedule
the memo Canada Mia and Mia and me at 10
Mall
I think my dog's a table you know it's just
I'm just complaining in both languages it's
like I have spent so much time abroad
spending money to learn languages and
spending time with International people and
I'm fucking stuck in front of my computer
everyday
oh that's a lot and I do not wish I could do
that and I cannot do it can I do that
and I thought when I was in college I
thought I was going to be like bouncing all
over the world that I was going to be
going to be you know an international
businessman I had international business
contacts all over the world I I took people
imprisoned everywhere I translate for people
I'm not bragging I just tell you I invested
all that time and energy and fucking money I
spent thousands of dollars on that and now
what
now what the only the only thing I can say
is that
this is got to be a part of the plan this
part right here this part right here at this
whole streaming thing because if it didn't
have this ago fucking insane and and I'm
happy when I'm here I get frustrated because
people shit on me all the time but and then
they tell me that I shouldn't people
is satellite as a second language on my God
that's so cool
I have to meet another person around those
Latin last fucking amazing I I really really
wish I learned it
it was she said it was going to be 32
degrees is supposed to be done
that he they're saying that you already know
Russian literature and I actually just
continue to read in Russian and it reads as
I can in the biggest Advantage is and you
know what you're absolutely right thank you
for saying that hack the Box you remind me
there is something that I can do that other
people can't and they are a particular set
of skills
and one of those skills is reading Russian
hacker boards
I can more or less read Russian hacker
boards and
it's something I'm sure it's a...
Yes yes this is very much so Christy nuke
someone that's so cool
yeah so so I will say that that's that has
been one of the advantages of it I mean
there's been other Advantage is my career my
early life was really related to my language
abilities and not so much my coding and
billing is more related to that
so that's why I'm done
do you think about learning Russian and if
he does tell me right now busy spending a
little bit every day has been trying to
learn it
is that they again I don't know if it's
everybody just needs to know this about me I
am a dumbass American man and I always use
he for people when they don't know their
gender and I'm a horrible person and I
apologize and try and Tuesday I honestly
don't know what your problem is I don't
really care to know so I do that all the
time I just I just don't want anybody to
think that I happen to know because I don't
and they would they might get the wrong
again
most most most Americans don't give a shit
about anything except for what's right in
front of them
and you can call me a negative person for
saying that I don't care I do not care
is this Teresa Ashes Remain
racism and there you go yeah we get a lot of
friends or friends from here up in here and
in France and Canada
and I really really appreciate you being
here I really do you have no idea
I really really do I do one of my first
thinking back you know two years of endeavor
streaming the first month a bunch of people
from friends came in and I was speaking
French with him in the whole entire night
was France and they were just showing me all
the pop culture for bread set everything in
municipality and bunch of stuff and catching
up on all Donald's that's the last pop
culture from France I know it was years ago
and it was just it was spectacular it was
absent spectacular and everything that piss
it sucks to be you and I wasn't putting
anybody down I was just
we're going to do this might as well be a
little selfish sometimes play Little Richard
do a little French pop culture read some
Russian hacker boards
go watch keep it again on the computer
keep it it's cool you got the back here
again
how can I hack the Box University
at the bluff
will it take me to get home keep it. Keep
it.
Flash I don't want you to quit yeah
you're stupid in any language I don't I
don't think you are no you're not I don't
think they probably
by The Starlight for pronouns between
photographs of people searches
oh God and like fairy Oh my God that's so
cool
when I was dating I had to think of my
profile it said phone IMS excite me
I trust that they do
she better.
Keep it Ridgid keybar Jade
I feel a thousand Subs restaurants
linear Bismol
I've got to go I can't do this right now
with everybody watching but I got to go
catch up I got to go catch up and cute stuff
and now another one that's the same threat
that many languages for their person that's
crazy
that's crazy
okay him docker
what did you send other stuff you need to do
sudo systemctl enable now Tucker
to try one more time so I'm going to bed if
this works really try a reprovision
they guarantee I keep typing it vagrant
vagrant
Reno Dash Dash provision
any Greek now I don't know no I spend all my
time five credit hour class does anybody
else have as anyone else ever heard of the
five credit hour college class that's so
sincere question I'm not I'm not trying to
brag and question I'm sincerely trying to
sincerely trying to to know
where is Russian at the University of that
Russian Russian 101 was the only 5 credit
hour class
and I'm trying to figure out there I'm
trying to find a comfortable classes of of
some sort and I can compare it to you out
there
because even you had she had to be so
immersed and I haven't be like a feeling
Chinese would have been four but I didn't we
didn't teach Chinese my number see I wish
they had all my God I wish they had the in
teaching
no they didn't didn't teach any Asian
languages I don't think I did anything that
any Asian languages
not that that's him and some other stuff but
not on there bam
the Greek would be a great language to learn
what's up what's that thing above the Matrix
that they say is Latin and it's actually
Greek
Something There Goes soon can we rent it
until I get it wrong and Matrix and Matrix
has
as the Matrix has a plaque above the door
when the grandmas eat incorrect got
chocolate chip cookies what's your face
torkoal
it's something similar to go sooner whatever
and it was written in Greek and everybody
says it's Latin the mix up all the time
Siri, when I know that's all I got to say
it's finished.
Vagrant SSH control
stalker is here doctor PS is not that's a
read on it
it darker dr. Salas no darker
images sweet we are set to go you know that
means
I don't know if I can
so I'm going to do the docker compose
enticing us up again and I'm going to do the
me to give the test a single notifications
that's what I'd be doing all day tomorrow
but this is the thing I want to do because
you look we're now on
assistant can I can pull down all kinds of
stuff on this and can you keep ATM
no they self that's the one right Tim and
yeah
there's a comedian okay so this is great
because this is
this is great we will finish everything
today we finish the whole the whole task I
finished the entire lab
yep
actually we finish this Force asking 383
virtual machines it took or Santa coming
around named Patrol
control node one and no two
receipts for the container engine in any
other Mission told you much
and tomorrow night I'm going to be
creating. How many days left abuse with 105
left
I want to get this done I want to get this
done before our communities moose
before this and we only have till February
5th so we only have like 2 more weeks I want
to get this all done before we do that
because you actually do have a developer
boost we can do all of that in many Cube we
can do all this to me to give a kind we
don't need to do any of that application
developer assumes you have a nice
environment you don't have to install it
that's not part of it
are you still online did you find it
diligent people yep
did they put the right thing at the about
the thing
operatives how do you say it but they self
I'll just get you nowhere I need to put this
in the autodidact thing I do
I need $0.50 out of that I think cuz it's
cuz that's important thing
yeah it is let's do
stuff to put in the beginning ruse Terrell
scales going to be
wait I think I put it in the Boost directory
don't forget yeah
all right that is cool
then what what do we do have that where did
where did where is Saul comedian
I think I don't know
I think your attitude is so cute I am first
actually yeah that guy most positive
onto control this can be our task for
tomorrow
tonight anyway yep swana is 1 x 12
I'm going to want to go ahead and drop and
and see how things go
anyway I'm going to say this to anybody else
wants to follow along
I did get ignore vagrant
there we go
I get commence complete first task
Kid Flash yep
I mean I don't use I don't need to do that
but here we go so there's a bigger file does
it does have it nice it's Ruby
so that's the solution
I can't figure out how to capture Solutions
of stuff in there I don't know how we need
to do that I said
and we have are you just has a task in it
if enemy have related we should probably go
the fear of the section we probably should
have links to the other lab to do those
other things
yep nice
I haven't you told him I don't know how I
feel about it I think it's nice that it's
been able to get much languages like Julian
Crystal and regionally rust a crystal music
but dumb I don't I don't know that makes me
like I think Joe is a much more of a work of
art because they were thrown off to my Scan
Power
and go self don't run time everything lvm
like kind of cheating
you can say that it's in a leveraging
existing thing blah blah blah but
it's a lot easier to make a language with
all them that it is which is sort of good
but dumb
that is a not sure if I like it oh yeah I'm
fucking huge fan of go-go as the most
important language on the planet right now
every every major cloud-native application
was written ago
every major one. He's dr. helm
whenever any form ethias
yeah they'll be an assembly so complex I
mean it it is easier so hard to
so
so yeah I do want to go programming on here
I just haven't done any lately I haven't
done any coronavirus right now I got a
really really take it up a notch on the
community service station stuff so I need to
stand up pretty fast I need a mailing
address for a class I need to fill out time
at bit when I'm not doing it I'm doing I'm
doing kotingo bash or something or whatever
whatever name the language today was Ruby
and I think you don't like putting all your
eggs in one basket and in like getting all
the tribal about a language really fucking
stupid actually it's really stupid do the
language that matches has to hand the end
and there's a few competitors for this
particular task but we can travel over
languages are stupid
and they do
so I no idea how big are actually has a huge
huge at Go-Go fits between Python and C
is there a my opinion my opinion you have a
simply see my liver you see on Friday and
Saturdays if your new we do see on Saturdays
we receive for 5 hours on Saturday we had
foreseen
so assembly see and then she was supposed to
be kind of share a spot
and then go
and above that you have you know the the
other compiled languages you probably Java
in terms of speed and level the level right
and then you get up to The Interpreter
language line Python and JavaScript review
parole
typescript whatever
so that's that's how they fit to me to me to
me Ruby I'm sorry and crystals actually
download there too
did you see you should see the bug they made
a big announcement about how awesome Ruby
about awesome rest of us today and elixir oh
yeah it looks a little too yeah but I'm
talking about like systems level images of
Department with you
I said a big a big to-do about the release
of rest today especially getting closer to
the colonel which is a total crush it at
shit I think it's so funny because the whole
world is totally being lied to and they
don't know they don't know it ain't nobody
bothers to read the actual emails exchanges
with Linda's revolves in the rest I don't
really give a shit they just read the blogs
and the Reddit posts in the stack exchange
series with a bunch of script kiddies
answering in a survey speakers are not
answering service and so I have to tell you
this though you still one of the things and
then in the rust blog and then rust thing
the progress thing was that they patched a
hole in in where the main system libraries
called command
which executes a shell and evaluates the
shell and executes a command that
automatically looked for any file in the
current. / directory
and if you're a hacker you know an assist by
the clothes they close the small hole they
close the small hole that automatically ran
anything in the current directory
above anything else
and it was in the standard Library it was
mrs. I am so glad that you all know this I
am so glad that you are here and you can
know what I'm saying because the people who
write that blog have no fucking idea for us
to get to 2022 with that bug in the standard
Library
just demonstrates what a fucking klusterfuk
rust is it's such a klusterfuk they don't
even see why that's a problem like well we
close the minor problem
are you kidding me you can drive a truck
through at security vulnerability I mean
it's it just drives me nuts it just drives
me nuts because rest is safe oh yeah it's
just perfect according to mr. Twitter right
mr. Twitter says rust is perfect riffed safe
go use rust nothing bad will happen God damn
it they just it's just so damn terrifying
this so damn terrifying and it was like an
afterthought didn't even talk about it they
didn't even talk about it I was like you've
got to be kidding me that's like that's like
automatically putting. / in everybody's path
what's really crazy about that is it you
could even do the right thing you could have
had your path correctly set and rust threw
it away and put. / in the front of your path
that's how fucked-up that is it's so fucked
up and yet it didn't get any attention and
the only attention that got was this
language is really awesome everybody wants
to be in the colonel by the way it might be
a driver language
I can hold you should learn its do I have to
shut out of it the people that are renting
imagine imagine imagine if a bunch of drama
script script kiddies suddenly systems code
with Russ imagine imagine that world and
then they put all that code running has
roots on a desktop
if you're a hacker you need to fucking learn
it because these people that already have no
idea what they're doing they have no idea
they have no idea they had no idea and there
and they keep
and they and they keep trying to get the
language closer and closer and they were
anyone else they were Champion they're like
oh we have we have string Littles no-sew
log4j comes out right literally the same
like the week before or the week after log4j
comes out right so the week after log4j
comes out guess what
the week after log4j comes out rust goes in
there and block and they brag about having
string literals the same exact sort of thing
that was taken advantage of for log project
and they're safe as far as I know I haven't
checked and I kind of want to they're safe
but they're bragging about hey guess what we
did we put string literals inside of our
strings just like everybody else and they're
like wait this awful lot like a Syntax for
the lock for jair are you sure you're not
evaluating anything besides just symbols and
stuff in there and I no no no we're doing it
perfectly safe and they probably are they
probably are differently on that particular
one I don't know but it's like they keep
solving problems that JavaScript people want
to have fixed you know they keep solving
these like tiny ass stupid thing from the
JavaScript world that that are not anywhere
near so it doesn't know what it wants to be
one second and wants to be the next
JavaScript it was a real problem was there
ever a semi next time I want to replace the
in the Linux kernel it doesn't have any idea
what it wants to be in his nobody were in
the ship and everybody on the moderators
team quit in disgust it's a it's a total
disaster if I were a company I cannot
believe
the people that are putting their companies
at risk
by biting it. I cannot believe it and they
think that it's a safer language I'll tell
you when it's okay it's just a foreign
language but you just put in the biggest
vulnerability and since the shell shell
shocked and you didn't even tell anybody
about it and you're lucky nobody caught you
on it you know I didn't catch you on it
because you haven't done anything
significant in Rust at all if there have
been any significant application done is for
us that use the command application I
guarantee it would have been exploited by
hackers have been giving a shit
but now it's time to give a shit when you go
hack the shit out of the only time the only
the only way you can bring The Shining Light
of Shame on something like rust after it's
gotten so beloved is to hack the shit out of
it and embarrassed at the death shame it to
death shame is creators to death and put it
out there for everybody to see what a
klusterfuk of a disaster it is so that it
can get on its way off of the you know that
the top of the hill of hype and then down
into the trough of disillusionment so we can
get on with real work and as I said I still
think she could be used for a lot of real
work but right now it's just like
yeah but after I saw that go container with
sleep takes 250 MB
that doesn't and now it doesn't that is I
don't know what you're looking at
I go container does not take that much it
was it a from scratch container I can do it
go from scratch container into MB and have
I don't know what you're talkin about
different trash container you'll see the
difference
I said I don't think it's 25 MB I'd be
really surprised python is definitely MB
that means you're like eliminating all the
standard library or something
are they going to hack
I'd actually did that comparison we did one
and see you what we should do on Saturday or
something we should do we should do a French
catch the hello world from presbyterian rust
Hill Road from scratch A and B on a whole
different computer and go as we can see you
again that we can hit we can evaluate then
once I'm outside
yeah go doesn't come with much many more
batteries included them
I don't know why would you ever put go in
Alpine that's ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous no need. That's that's
that's a fundamental misunderstanding of
containers in my opinion the whole point of
go the reason go is the darling of container
land is because you can do from scratch
containers that you can never ever ever do
with python by the NFL have felt whole
fucking OS do a French catch container and
you drop all the OS there's no ass at all
it's just a single container that has all
everything built in that you want and really
Kick-Ass in today she pee and everything
else when you're going on a good idea to see
you guys I got to go get the baby ready I'll
give it a shot though
we can raid forgotten VCR I love forgotten
VCR we're getting these are really fun
and that whoever does forgot to be sure they
work really hardyeah they work really hard
at it
so have fun tell him I please tell him hello
for me by
all right by everybody